what's up Wolfgang with the digital
release of Avengers infinity war we are
just getting so much new information so
many questions about infinity war that
we had are being answered one of them
was do you have to be worthy or not to
lift Stormbreaker
if you haven't figured that out yet you
can check out a video I did on it in the
link above also I'm doing a giveaway
giving away a few copies of Avengers
infinity war blu-ray all you have to do
to enter is be subscribed to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your favorite superhero so through some
commentaries on the digital release of
Avengers infinity war we have learned a
little bit more about the Infinity
Gauntlet
so obviously the Infinity Gauntlet gives
the wielder of it the power to control
and handle the Infinity stones as Eitri
says in infinity war
it's a device capable of harnessing the
power of the stones as we learn in other
movies such as guardians of the galaxy
the stones are simply too powerful for
just anyone to be able to control you
have to be an extremely powerful being
to even just hold one which is why you
see people like Ronan infuse the stones
with an object and even then it's still
super hard to control so imagine more
than one stone imagine if somebody tried
to hold two stones at one time no one
could really do it no one in the MCU at
least right now could do it Thanos is
the only person and it seems fairly
obvious that even he himself cannot
handle them all at once which is why he
has a tree form him the Infinity
Gauntlet so with the ability to harness
the power of more than one Infinity
stone you're pretty much unstoppable the
Power Stone alone has the ability to
wipe out worlds so with Thanos
possessing such great power throughout
the whole entire movie how do you make a
movie to where the Avengers stand even a
remote chance against him the way you do
that according to writer Stephen McFeely
is you create a small physical rule that
allows the Avengers to hang in the fight
so there's a catch and that catches
Thanos has to close his fists in order
to use the power of the Infinity
this was a choice that the directors
made as sort of a bare minimum
requirement for Thanos to use the stones
because without that there really is no
fight in the comics it's pretty much if
you think it happens an example of this
is in the Infinity Gauntlet series where
nebula wields the Infinity Gauntlet
Nebula makes a mistake and when she
rectifies this mistake she says a
mistake even the wretched thing that I
was can rectify with but enough thought
so if Thanos can just think anything he
wants and use the power of the stones
and then the Avengers really have no
chance at all so now that you know this
fact about the Infinity Gauntlet that
the analyst actually has to close his
fists in order to use the stones pay
close attention to the scenes that you
watch in Avengers infinity war if you
notice on the scene on Titan when our
heroes are fighting Thanos everything
that they're trying to do is to keep
Thanos from closing his fist it even
starts off by Doctor Strange telling his
cloak
don't let him close his fist in which
the cloak attacks Thanos his hand and
keeps him from closing the gauntlet
everything from Doctor Strange sending
his cloak atom to Spiderman webbing his
hand up to Iron Man putting a device on
the garland that doesn't allow him to
close it it's all an effort to keep him
from closing his fist so he can't use
the power of the Infinity stones so this
was the only reason that our heroes
really even had a remote fighting chance
when they were fighting Thanos
unfortunately for our heroes even
without the Infinity stones Thanos is
just the most powerful being really in
the universe at this point at least that
we've been introduced to and he manages
to find them all off and ultimately use
the Infinity Gauntlet to defeat them all
and then goes on to collect all the
stones and then so it's an interesting
fact that we learned about the Infinity
Gauntlet and it makes a lot of sense
that the writers would put this in there
because how do you really have a movie
without this small physical catch but
this tiny flaw in the gauntlet could
really be the only way that the Avengers
could defeat Thanos in Avengers 4
clearly this was done intentionally so
did the writers put this in here for the
Avengers to have a chance against Thanos
in Avengers 4 could this be the way they
defeat him I certainly think so
but what do you all think and did you
happen to connect the dots in Avenger
infinity war where dr. strange towed his
cloak don't let him close his fist hit
me with all of your thoughts in the
comments below
and again another reminder about the
giveaway I'm doing all you have to do to
enter to win a copy of Avengers infinity
war on blu-ray is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your favorite superhero thank
you so much for watching woof woof
[Music]
you